Thanks to CuriosityStream for supporting PBS
Digital Studios.
Our world isn’t just some big rock we live
on.
It’s an ever-changing environment, with
countless creatures – us included – just
trying to survive.
That’s why as an engineer, you have to think
about how you affect the world and how the
world affects us.
If we want to try and live in harmony with
nature, we need environmental engineering.
[Theme Music]
Environmental engineering combines natural sciences
like chemistry and biology with engineering principles to
come up with solutions to environmental problems.
It boils down to three main things:
protecting people from the environment,
protecting the environment from people,
and improving the overall quality of the
world around us.
As an environmental engineer, you’ll be
looking into issues such as public health
and sustainability.
You’ll be especially concerned with controlling
air and water quality.
The air we breathe and the water we drink
are crucial to life itself, and even simple
changes can lead to serious problems.
Take, for instance, what happened in Flint,
Michigan.
After switching the city’s water source
to the Flint River back in 2014, Flint’s
drinking water became dangerous.
Untreated river water corroded the pipes,
contaminating the water with lead.
Lead consumption affects everything from your
heart to your brain, leading to cardiovascular problems
like elevated blood pressure and hypertension,
as well as neurological issues like
increased aggression or difficulty thinking.
The contamination was also tied to an outbreak
of Legionnaires’ diseases that caused at least
12 deaths.
One study even found that fertility rates
decreased by 12% and fetal death rates went
up by more than half.
Solving the problem isn’t just about switching
Flint’s drinking water back to a better source.
All of the city’s damaged pipes need to
be replaced before the water will truly be
safe to drink again.
It will take years to fix what could’ve
been avoided.
The lesson here is that you need to make sure
whatever water source you’re using, it isn’t going
to mess up any systems already in place.
We now know that water from the Flint River
should’ve been treated with alkaline chemicals to
reduce corrosivity before being fed into the city’s pipes.
It’s not just drinking water –
you need to be concerned with water quality
whenever you’re dealing with an aquatic environment,
like a natural water supply that houses fish.
Flint’s problem was rooted in human safety,
but just as often it’s the safety of other organisms
you need to be worried about.
It’s critical that your work doesn’t dramatically
alter the local water’s natural characteristics.
Like, for instance, its dissolved oxygen content.
Fish and other aquatic creatures need to consume
oxygen from the water around them in order to survive.
It’s impossible to perfectly predict the
amount of dissolved oxygen needed,
but in general, a level of about 4-5 parts per million
is usually the bare minimum necessary to support
an underwater population.
Get up to 9 parts per million and you have a
thriving community, but drop below 3 and even
the toughest fish won’t be able to survive.
Cold water can hold more dissolved oxygen
than warm water, so cooling off a lake can
help to correct low levels.
Photosynthesis from the water’s plants will
also produce oxygen, so it might not be a
bad idea to add some greenery, too.
Another thing to worry about is the pH level:
how acidic or basic is it?
Pure water has a pH level of 7.
Below 7 is acidic and above 7 is basic.
Generally, a pH range of about 6 to 8 supports
life.
But go too far outside of these levels and
you’ll start running into trouble, especially
on the lower end.
Fish will usually start to die at pH levels
under 5.
More acidic water can also leach
metals from your pipes, such as copper,
zinc, or lead – like in Flint.
Drinking water with a higher pH level isn’t
as dangerous,
but it can cause drinks to taste bitter and
lead to mineral build-up in your plumbing,
which makes it harder for water to flow.
You can try to correct out-of-range pH levels
by adding other chemicals to the water, but those
need to be supportive of your overall system.
For instance, if you’re adding salt to try and correct
out-of-range pH levels, you could throw off the water’s
salinity, or the amount of dissolved salt.
That definitely won’t taste the best, but
it reduces the dissolved oxygen; in environmental
engineering, everything is connected.
You can tell how much salt is in the water
by measuring its conductivity, or how well
electricity flows through it.
The more salt, the more ions, and the better
the water will conduct electricity.
And any hormones that make their way into a
water supply can have pretty substantial effects.
Many of the medicines you take end up in
your sewage and can affect entire aquatic
populations.
Estrogen is especially important because it’s
hard to filter out.
When released at the right concentrations,
scientists have seen it change the sex of
entire schools of fish!
There are many other factors that affect water quality,
like how clear the water is, what nutrients are in it, and
if it has any viruses or bacteria swimming around.
But no matter the problem, you need to treat
it.
And you don’t just want to play clean-up
after a disaster – you want to try to snuff
out the problem at the source.
One way to remove unwanted material is through
a process called coagulation.
It works by adding a chemical like aluminum
sulfate that causes small particles to stick
together, or coagulate.
As they clump, they become larger and easier
to remove with something like a filter.
You can clean water by focusing on things
like rivers and sewers.
It’s a whole different problem to clean
something that’s all around us, like the air.
From exhaust fumes to smokestacks and insecticides,
there are countless forms of airborne pollution.
Factories are among the largest culprits, producing
chemicals like carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide
as byproducts of the combustion process.
Breathing in too much carbon monoxide can
lead to flu-like symptoms, such as dizziness,
weakness, and vomiting.
Enough exposure can even be fatal.
Every year, more than 20,000 people in the US end up
in the emergency room, due to non-fire related carbon
monoxide poisoning, so this is a pretty big problem.
When pollutants like these get in the air,
you need to find out not just how they got there,
but how far they’re going to travel.
High wind speeds and storms will be able to
carry the pollutants farther than a light breeze.
But probably the biggest thing you need to
be concerned about is the size of the pollutants.
The smaller they are, the harder it is to
filter them out.
For example, bacteria are typically bigger
than viruses.
If your friend has a cold that they don’t
want to spread, they should wear a face mask
with extremely small pores.
Remember, the common cold is a virus, so the
pores need to be smaller than if they were just
trying to stop the spread of everyday bacteria.
Filters can remove many pollutants from the
air, but they come with some limitations.
Some of the smallest particles can slip through
and larger ones clog things up, so they need to be
replaced even when working properly.
That’s where absorption towers come in.
They combine liquid falling from above with
air rising from below to remove many kinds
of particles.
Another way to remove pollutants is by using
an electrostatic air filter.
These are made up of multiple layers of vented metal
and essentially work like a magnet for any unwanted
particles floating in the air, such as dust, mold, or pollen.
As air passes through the first layer of metal,
the molecules in the air are positively charged by
the friction between the air and the filter.
With their new positive charge, the molecules will attach themselves to the next couple of layers as they try to pass through the rest of the filter, essentially getting trapped inside.
So not only will a good air filtration system
help block out deadly pollutants, but it can
also help save you from a runny nose!
Air and water quality are just two of the
problems addressed by environmental engineering,
but others include things like noise pollution
and waste management.
Loud noises may not sound that important, but spend
some time trying to think next to a construction site,
and you’ll realize how harmful noise pollution can be.
And many of the things that we make, make
noise.
Cars are a big one.
Left unattended, highways can be a major source
of noise pollution.
That’s why you’ll see those wall-like
sound barriers on the side of the road.
Factories and places with a lot of loud machinery
can also disrupt their neighbors.
Earplugs may be enough for the workers inside,
but if a factory is making too much noise,
it might need a more sound-proof building
or to be put in a less residential area.
You also have to find a way manage all of
the trash you create, whether that’s piling it up
in landfills or finding ways to recycle.
Recycling isn’t just about reducing pollution – it also
helps conserve natural resources like timber and saves
energy, which might come from fossil fuels.
It’s not only small things like soda cans,
either.
Computers, cars, and even abandoned buildings
can all be recycled.
Many of the chemical reactions involved with
engineering also produce waste, so you need to get
rid of that too, especially if it’s hazardous.
Sometimes you can treat the hazardous materials
and eliminate the danger outright,
but other times you might have to settle for simply
storing it as best as possible.
If you have to do that, you need to make sure
that the waste won’t react with, weaken, or
dissolve whatever container you put it in.
All of these things – and so much more – must
be considered when approaching problems from
an environmental engineering perspective.
But as long as you take the proper precautions,
you’ll be on the right path to keeping this world spinning.
Today we learned all about environmental engineering
and the work that goes into managing our impact on
the environment, and its impact on us.
We found out the importance of water quality
and how differing levels of dissolved oxygen,
pH, and salinity can affect it.
Then we saw how air quality matters and the
different types of pollution we have to deal with.
Finally, we went into other issues, like noise
pollution and waste management, and saw how
they can affect us too.
I’ll see you next time, when we’ll learn
about alternative energy.
Thank you to CuriosityStream for supporting
PBS Digital Studios.
CuriosityStream is a subscription streaming service that offers documentaries and non-fiction titles from a variety of filmmakers, including CuriosityStream originals.
For instance, CuriosityStream has “Nature’s
Mathematics,” a series about patterns and
symmetry in nature.
Nature’s Mathematics explores the rules
that shape trees and river estuaries alike,
and that continue to baffle scientists by
their often unfathomable ubiquity.
You can learn more at curiositystream.com/crashcourse
and use the code crashcourse during the sign-up process.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios, which also produces
Hot Mess, a show about how climate change
impacts all of us, and what we can do about it.
Head to the link in the description to find
out how we can create a better future for
our planet and ourselves.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.